the end of the world is officially upon
us because now precisely five years and
one day ago Saint Greta of the Blessed
sailboat Miss thundberg herself
predicted it she tweeted in a curiously
deleted tweet a top climate scientist
how dare you she said a top climate
scientist is warning that climate change
will wipe out all of humanity unless we
stop using fossil fuels over the next
five years to be fair to Greta she did
not say that the world would end in five
years she said that climate change would
wipe out all of humanity unless we stop
using fossil fuels over the next five
years and those are different claims but
the Practical consequence of them is
pretty similar whether we're already
dead or merely inevitably doomed there
is now according to Greta thornberg
absolutely no reason to try to do
anything about so-called climate change
it's too late